[Musique]
bienvenue en débat sur france 24 gasprom
suspend toutes ses livraisons de gaz
vers la bulgarie et la pologne une
suspension car les deux pays ont refusé
de plier ce gaz en roubles c'est ce qu'a
affirmé moscou c'est la conséquence
d'actes hostiles inédit contre la russie
a également lancé le kremlin réponse du
premier ministre polonais son pays ne
cédera pas à ce chantage grâce à ses
réserves de gaz suffisantes
l'union européenne s'était préparé à une
interruption de gaz russe et organise
une réponse coordonnée a ajouté la
présidente de la commission européenne
ursula von der leyen cet après midi or
le gaz est il la remet économique russe
dans le conflit ukrainien quelle sera la
réponse des européens l'europe de l'est
mais aussi l'europe occidentale
peut-elle vraiment se passer de gaz
russe on en débat avec mes invités j'ai
le plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés anastasia
chapeau qui n'a bonsoir maître de
conférences en géopolitique à sciences
po présidente du think tank est stone
sour cause et spécialistes europe russie
également spécialiste de la géopolitique
de l'énergie et bien bienvenue dans le
débat à côté de vous nous avons francis
perrin bonsoir directeur de recherche à
l'iris spécialiste des questions
énergétiques et chercheur associé au
policy center for de new south bienvenue
à vous et bonsoir également par skype de
varsovie en pologne georges mink georges
mink directeur de recherche cnrs émérite
à l'institut des sciences sociales du
politique spécialiste de l'europe
occidentale et centrale expert du
collège d'europe à varsovie bonsoir à
vous et bienvenus
nous attendons dans quelques minutes
parce qu'il est un porc par jean de
gliniasty l'ancien ambassadeur de france
en russie avant de débattre je vous
propose de faire un point en images avec
kevin batista
gasprom ferment le robinet du gaz depuis
ce mercredi la pologne la bulgarie ne
sont plus approvisionnée en gaz russe
faute d'avoir payé leur dernière facture
en roubles la présidente de la
commission européenne dénonce un
chantage
l'annnonce de gazprom est une nouvelle
provocation du kremlin c'est la
confirmation sans surprise femme que le
kremlin utilisent les énergies fossiles
pour tenter de nous faire du chantage et
c'est quelque chose que la commission
européenne avait un sens
l'accusation est rejetée par la russie
après l'invasion de l'ukraine et les
sanctions occidentales moscou avait
annoncé le mois dernier ne plus accepter
que des paiements en roubles de la part
de certains pays
nous avons agi ainsi car vous le savez
un montant significatif de nos réserves
a été gelé en d'autres termes volée donc
il n'est pas question de chantage toutes
les nouvelles modalités avaient été
signalés à l'avance aux acheteurs
la pologne la bulgarie seront désormais
fournis par les autres pays membres de
l'ue à court terme pas d'inquiétude donc
pour l'exécutif polonais nos stockages
de gaz et son plein à 76% il s'agit d'un
taux de remplissage élevé bien supérieur
à celui des autres pays européens
varsovie compte demander des pénalités
pour non respect des clauses du contrat
par moscou la pologne importait 45% de
son gaz de russie une dépendance encore
plus forte pour la bulgarie 90% de gaz
russe dans ses importations
au-delà de ces deux pays c'est toute
l'union européenne qui cherchent des
alternatives aux énergies russe des
négociations avec la norvège l'algérie
et le qatar notamment seraient déjà
engagés et on va écouter tout de suite
la dîmière poutine
si quelqu'un de l'extérieur
intervient dans les événements il crée
des menaces stratégie inacceptable pour
nous
il doit savoir que notre réponse sera
immédiate
rapide
nous disposons de tous les instruments
dont on pourrait rêver
on a six
straumann anastasia chapeau ch qui n'a
pourquoi la russie coupe-t-elle la
livraison de gaz à la pologne à la
bulgarie maintenant est-ce que ce gaz
est vraiment une arme que moscou compte
utiliser effectivement le gaz c'est
l'art que moscou conflit qui lisent et
on a pouvait s'en douter déjà dès la
déclaration donc 17 conditions
contractuelles nouvelles de payer à en
roubles pour toutes les livraisons ont
donc du gaz russe ensuite la tentative
de moscou de lier le rouble alors si
donc ce qu'ils ne referaient a qu'un
investisseur n'y a qu'un client dans
qu'est ce que exactement vos le rouble
comme les rues sont parfaites à
contrôler de la complicité de l'imprimé
est aussi un carton contrôle partiel de
la capacité de produire plus d'or alors
pourquoi la pologne à la bouille
milliards maintenant et donc parce que
des efforts donc envoyer maintenant le
signal des camps on en est à se demander
tous des pluies quels sont les
négociations derrière avec tous les
états et surtout les contrats mais
négociations financiers l'allemagne a
dit officiellement que ils vont pas
payer un rouble mais on sait pas qu
est-ce qui négocie les groupes almont
derrière par contre la russie a dû
envoyer le signal fort et là ils ont
commencé par la pologne comme la police
est en état vraiment décisive parmi tous
les états membres de l'union européenne
surtout pour livraison d'armes aux as à
l'ukraine et aussi pour les que des
réfugiés ils craignent un agrément le
partenaire stratégique le plus important
dans le sens purement physique proximité
de l'ukraine donc envoyé un signal tout
de suite georges mink est ce que
finalement la russie veut punir les
polonais
des cela mais c'est aussi un exemple
qu'elle en fait à envoyer à d'autres
pays de l'union européenne y compris
pour provoquer une scission à
l'intérieur de ce front commun
qui est tellement solide maintenant
jusqu'au point d'avoir surpris
potennerie donc c'est une manière
évidemment de d'enfoncer un coin entre
les différents pays dont les belles
soirées consommation du gaz russe sont
différenciés le degré de dépendance on
différencie aussi mais ça vaut la peine
de souligner que la le coût est mal
partie parce que comme l'a dit le
premier ministre polonais la parade a
été préparée de longue date il ya
d'abord des réserves souterraines
pratiquement à 75% donc ça permet de
tenir pendant une assez longue période
ensuite la pologne a préparé aussi des
livraisons venant d'autres gazoducs
d'autres pays elle a un gaz au port
construit exprès pour cela juste pour
garantir une certaine autarcie de
consommation de gasoil à août arte dont
on va y revenir justement georges 2012
doit juste faire réagir d'abord francis
perrin justement sûr qu'on comprenne
bien que l'importation du gaz russe en
pologne se fait par exemple via un
gazoduc qui s'appelle le gazoduc yamal
on va on a une carte justement on va
voir ce gazoduc quand la russie francis
perrin évoque cette question du rouble à
ce que c'est un prétexte un moyen
justement d'exercer un certain sens
chantage puisque on a l'impression que
gazprom peut faire la conversion
finalement entre une devises comme le
dollar ou l'euro en roubles sans aucun
problème c'est uniquement un prétexte si
c'était véritablement une raison pour
couper les approvisionnements
il n'y aurait pas que deux pays de
l'union européenne à qui gazprom devrait
couper le gaz puisque à l'exception de
la hongrie du monsieur viktor orban tous
les autres pays importants de gaz russe
ont dit nous n'allons pas accepter cette
condition elle est contraire à tous les
contrats que nous avons s'il y avait 15
corps donc c'est purement et simplement
un prétexte que gace promet en avant
pour donner une façade de l'égalité à
une décision qui est complètement
illégal au regard des contrats que
gazprom a signé avec les différentes
sociétés gazières européennes y compris
en pologne et en bulgarie donc là on est
face à une décision politique vous
traînez c'est bien dans ce secteur qui
n'est pas nouvelle c'est une décision
complètement politique
justement là vous pouvez intervenir
alizée genre bing justement les polonais
se sont préparés donc il n'était pas
très surpris en revanche il me semble
que les bulgares étaient beaucoup plus
surpris
pendant 90 % des livraisons du gaz et
mais c'est une émission d'une certaine
façon dans la situation politique
bulgare parce que nous sommes
là dans une compétition électorale où le
parti socialiste
horus évidemment est opposée à la
livraison d'armes pour l'ukraine et donc
c'est une manière de faire pression
aussi sur la scène politique mais je
voudrais dire juste une chose c'est
derrière ce raisonnement concernant le
payement roubles ya quand même un petit
calcul économique puisque il s'agit
d'une double comptabilité en fait le
pays contractants seront amenés à payer
en euros qui seront versés sur un compte
particulier transformée par la suite en
roubles ce qui donne et avec des délais
de transformation pour les livraisons ce
qui donne évidemment là un moyen de
contrôle à la russie sur les livraisons
les polonais par exemple disent très
clairement mais qu'est-ce qui se passera
s'il déclare que notre argent n'est pas
transformé dans les délais en roubles
vont-ils coupé ou pas donc il ya un jeu
qu un peu complexe qui tient aussi à la
stabilité du rouble l'humain chapeau
chinois oui une sorte de chantage qui
exerçait alors comment les polonais se
sont ils préparés nous en dise à un mot
jasmin qui s'y attendait c'est
l'utilisation du charbon finalement aux
en pologne qui va finalement se
substituer à cette utilisation du gaz
russe c'est la question qui va
s'adresser aussi à toute l'union
européenne donc là on a souvent parlé
ensuite on termine sont justement la
pologne lui donc sur la pelouse c'est le
charbon comme la pologne c'est un des
producteurs de charbon le plus important
dans l'union européenne avec l'allemagne
la république tchèque 6 c'est aussi à le
gaz par le gnl donc qui peut être le gaz
américain qui peut être aussi le gaz
qatari sera donc n'importe quelle source
par gnl qui permet aujourd'hui à laleu
union européenne y compris la pologne
d'être compétitifs parce que les prix du
gaz européen aujourd'hui sont
compétitifs avec le prix du gaz
asiatique historiquement le plus bleu
plus haut on va écouter justement la
ministre du climat la ministre polonaise
nous sommes prêts à être totalement
coupée des ressources aux russes nous
avons imposé un embargo sur le charbon
le 16 avril nous sommes prêts pour une
coupure complète des importations de gaz
et de pétrole russe
win havre
francis perrin justement donc elle peut
se substituer elle a ce qu'il faut
disons la pologne pour ne pas utiliser
ce gaz russe elle peut se passer du gaz
russe l'apologue de toute façon avait
annoncé la couleur le contrat
d'importation de gaz russe arrive à
expiration fin de cette année et les
dirigeants polonais avait dit nous
n'allons pas le renouveler ce qui veut
dire qu'il s'est préparé ils ne sont ils
ne se disent pas on va arrêter
d'importer du gaz et on n'a rien
évidemment aucun gouvernement de frais
sont donc les deux autres intervenants
ont donné un certain nombre d'éléments
la pologne produit un peu de gaz pas
suffisamment pour ses besoins mais par
les temps qui courent il vaut mieux en
produire un peu que pas du tout on a
évoqué la question du gaz naturel
liquéfié la pologne à un terminal pour
recevoir des méthaniers qui transporte
du gaz naturel liquéfié d'où elle a en
particulier alors notamment des états
unis comme l'a dit monsieur nick mais de
tous les pays qui produisent du gaz
naturel liquéfié ça pourrait être le cas
par et qui ont évidemment des volumes
supplémentaires à ventre et ensuite il
ya des conditions commerciales à voir la
pologne à partir du mois prochain c'est
à dire quasiment demain sera relié à la
lituanie par un gazoduc la lituanie a
aussi un terminal pour recevoir des
méthaniers et à partir de l'automne il y
aura un nouveau gazoduc venant de
norvège alors celui là quand on
additionne bref ça mais ce gazoduc
norvège va suffire à ce qui va se
substituer aux autres il n'y a pas une
solution qui permet de remplacer le gaz
russe il faut mettre ensemble plusieurs
solutions il y a un peu de production
nationale il y a des stocks importants
cela était évoqué des stocks souterrains
en pologne il y a importations de gaz
naturel liquéfié par la pologne
possibilité d'en apporter par la
lituanie dans les semaines qui viennent
un nouveau gazoduc et la solidarité
européenne avec un réseau de gazoducs
interconnecté avec tout ça la pologne
pourra se passer sans problème du gaz
russe par contre le cas de la bulgarie
est plus complexe justement on va
l'écouter on va écouter la preuve et
istres bouillard qui a également réagi
le premier pardon ce terrain tôt la
coupure de gaz de la part de gazprom est
une violation flagrante de leur contrat
et un chantage à l'utilisation d'un plan
de paiement rouble qui ne fait pas
partie du contrat et doit être fait par
des tiers qui ne garantissent ni les
livraisons ni l'argent des bulgares nous
ne céderons pas intel raquette
la bulgarie réexamine également tous les
contrats avec gazprom y compris le
contrat de transit par la bulgarie car
un acte unilatéral de chantage est
inacceptable aimait beaucoup ce team est
là c'est plus compliqué pour les
bulgares absolument donc les bulgares
par contre pourrait peut-être envisager
donc dans le futur des ressources de
sources de livraison
parmi les sources à des raisons
alternatifs par exemple l'azerbaïdjan
qui est devenue l'année dernière donc un
des nouveaux livreur du gaz naturel par
le 'pipeline' donc à vers l'union
européenne et dont les livraisons
restent très limitées vert à 16
milliards de mètres cubes par an tu mets
qui peuvent potentiellement être et
étendue et donc c'est pour mes vives
yad'autres à d'autres structures mais
aussi en travers du gazoduc a donc
interne à l'union européen parce que là
les flux du gaz sont possibles passeront
donc de l'est ou à l'ouest mais aussi de
l'ouest à l'est et donc peut-être sept
systèmes pourraient aussi être utilisés
en utilisant donc le gaz venant par une
soif de l'algérie soit de la norvège
soit des terminaux de gnl vers la
bulgarie ou sip france espérant pourquoi
est-ce que c'est plus compliqué pour les
bulgares vous disais c'est plus
compliqué parce que leurs stocks sont
beaucoup moins importants que liszt au
polonais par rapport à leur consommation
et ça ça compte dans ce type de crise
parce que ils n'apportent pas de gaz
naturel liquéfié des parce qu'ils sont
moins relié au réseau gazier de l'union
européenne que la pologne qui est relié
à l'allemagne à la république tchèque
est donc bientôt dans quelques semaines
à l'habituel donc c'est un problème plus
délicat mais ça ne veut pas dire que
l'union européenne ne doit pas
évidemment apporter une assistance
importante pour montrer à monsieur
poutine que ce type de décision ont
choisi parmi 27 pays
2 que l'on veut punir suscite une
réponse de l'ensemble de l'union
européenne et jean de gliniasty nous a
rejoint ancien ambassadeur de france en
russie bonsoir vous êtes également
directeur de recherche à l'iris
peut-être que vous voulez réagir
justement sur cette question bulgare
pourquoi finalement la russie pourquoi
vous lier poutine veut-il déstabiliser
un pays qui a priori plutôt pro-russe en
tout cas beaucoup moins impliquées dans
la livraison des armes que la pologne
alors je me suis posé la question
peut-être qu'ils ont été plus réticents
que les autres à utiliser le système de
paiement via
gazprombank parce que visiblement les
allemands n'ont pas de réticence à le
faire et je pense que les français
doivent le faire c'est à vous payer en
devises et puis c'est la gazprombank qui
change en roubles donc cela ils ont eu
des difficultés mais je crois que sur le
fond il ya peut-être des raisons
politiques puisque est d'ailleurs le
la déclaration officielle russe fait
enfin mention de caractère inamical tap
il parle pas de questions du rouble est
en fait je crois bon la pologne c'est
évident c'est évident on en a parlé tous
là mais la bulgarie la bulgarie un
expert militaire m'a dit que la bulgarie
est le seul pays de l'union européenne à
produire encore des obus haut calibre au
calibre russe et donc ils peuvent
alimenter les obusiers que l'on donne et
même les obusiers ukrainiens ont nos bus
adaptés doriz alimenterait santé peuvent
ils doivent le faire sans le dire et
c'est peut-être une mesure de
représailles mais c'est une hypothèse
c'est une hypothèse georges lui
convenait d'accord avec cette hypothèse
que j'ai également déjà entendu qu'il
livrerait tout de même peut-être en
douce ces fameuses la vue comme
plusieurs pays derrière de la zone mais
et c'est tout à fait probable mais ce
qui est certain aussi ce qu'il ya cet
aspect politique j'ai signalé tout à
l'heure c'est qu'il ya une tension à
l'intérieur de la bulgarie sur les
livraisons entre un parti qui est
pro-russe et qui se bat pour avoir la
gouvernance et les autres partis qui
sont pour les livraisons et donc c'est
une manière d'une certaine façon
d'asphyxier la bulgarie pour donner la
voix à ce parti chorus qui lui
bloquerait les livraisons justement
c'est une manière aussi de faire
pression politiquement tout simplement
mais je rends passera sans doute à la
question de l'union européenne où j'ai
quand même un mois dit avait bien sûr
envoyée on va y passer tout de suite on
va écouter ou sous la forme des
relayeurs
nous allons faire en sorte que la
décision de gazprom et le moins d'impact
possible sur les consommateurs européens
la pologne et la bulgarie reçoivent
désormais du gaz de leurs voisins
européens
cela montre tout d'abord gymanse les a
été entre nous mais cela montre aussi
l'efficacité des investissements passés
par exemple en ce qui concerne les
interconnectés et autres infrastructures
de gaza une fois ce match
anastasia donc l'europe s'était préparé
à cette interruption du gaz russe et il
ya une réponse solide et à ce que ça
rejoint ce dont vous parliez ctc en fait
ces oléoducs européens qui peuvent
justement se substituer à ce gaz russe
donc il y à déjà il faut se rappeler les
chiffres donc
les expos russe et sow sont responsables
de 40 7% des importations de charbon de
l'union européenne 41 % des importations
du gaz 1 7% des importations du pétrole
donc là quand on parle de l'ambition
prononcée par la commission européenne
dans paris ou de remplacer trois quarts
des importations du gaz russe d'ici
octobre ou du cif en année c'est simple
quand même être très ambitieux et très
ambitieux est ce que c'est faisable
véritablement est justement et c'est
peut-être un peu faisant commencer
peut-être à part faisable tout à fait
complètement parce que selon les calculs
pas de par l' agence d'international de
l'énergie il y a que même à avancer en
moins baisse de 11 sera dépendante ou
dresseurs dépendantes toujours d'ici la
fin d'année on ment pour vinci pour 100
de des importations du gaz russe
directement à cause de la demande
croissante en algérie donc une des
sources des importations elle a de la
capacité de norvège de croître leur
propre production juste assez sûr sur
certaines limites les décisions
politiques de l'est des pays-bas de ne
pas accroître leur production est pour
pour les raisons du coup c'est smic et
politique aussi et ensuite des tout ce
qui aide les dynamiques de marché qui
peut toujours en france et les décisions
des exportateurs soit américain soit
qatar du gnl francis perrin parce que
c'est vrai que pour l'instant il n'y a
que deux mais il risque d'y en avoir
d'autres l'allemagne évidemment est un
peu se dit que c'est en tout cas le
prochain est-ce que effectivement
l'union européenne va pouvoir faire face
comme elle le dit avant la fin de
l'année comme vous venez de le dire
l'objectif euros bien moins deux tiers
pour les importations de gaz russe en un
an me paraît pas très réaliste la
commission européenne a donc produit ce
chiffre est l'agent s'intercale de
l'énergie lay up basée à paris avait
fait destituer évidemment sur ce même
sujet et avait dit on pense que dans un
an l'union européenne pourrait réduire
ses importations de gaz russe il avait
expliqué comment de 1/3 à 50% c'est déjà
très ambitieux et sans appareil beaucoup
plus réaliste que moins deux tiers en un
an donc 50 bourses de chiffres la 52e un
tiers à 50 % en un an s'est déjà très
ambitieux si on fait ça déjà c'est très
bien et il faut ensuite aller plus loin
il ya l'objectif à court terme réduire
de façon importante nos importations de
gaz russe en gros dans un an et
l'objectif à moyen terme 5 ans se passer
complètement du pétrole et du gaz russe
deux objectifs très ambitieux mais en un
an moins d'un an - deux tiers pour le
gaz russe ça me paraît
excessif georges mink est effectivement
si demain la russie coupe le gaz à
l'allemagne est-ce que ça risque d'être
très problématique l'allemagne peut-elle
se passer de gaz russe et pourra-t-elle
se passait de gaz russe avant la fin de
l'année parce que eux aussi ont un plan
de sortir de cette dépendance
oui le problème de l'allemagne aussi
c'est d'avoir refusé complètement les
nucléaire donc sans doute c'est le pays
qui a le plus de problèmes en plus avec
ce penchant
qui tente on soupçonne ce pays où
surtout la social démocratie allemande
d'être au russe d'une certaine façon
mais je crois que c'est assez formidable
d'observer que finalement tout ce que
fait poutine y actuellement
réflète quand quelque chose une friture
de panique de la part des poutines
puisque aucune aucun de ces projets ne
se réalisent
jusqu'ici elle attaque
énergétique qu'ils pratiquent produit
l'effet opposé puisque dans l'union
européenne depuis déjà un certain temps
sur la table il ya une discussion sur
l'union énergétique donc une plus forte
communautarisation des questions
énergétiques et avec l'action des
poutines bien sûr il va accélérer ce
processus
et c'est en cela qu'il ya un certain
espoir d'une plus profonde intégration
européenne mais en attendant comment
fait-on jean de gliniasty à ce qu
effectivement bon là on voit bien que
l'europe et restent unis enfin si demain
il n'y a plus de gaz russe en allemagne
elles n'ont pas le temps encore de
pouvoir vraiment trouver des solutions
moi je vins c'est évidemment un avis
très personnel mais je pense que
l'allemagne ne sacrifiera pas son
développement industriel et que si elle
n'arrive pas à s'adapter elle continuera
à prendre du gaz russe il ya aussi un
élément qu'il faut bien voir c'est que
même l'ukraine d'une certaine façon a
intérêt à ce que ça continue parce que
l'ukraine touche 1 milliard par an de
transit même plus que ça d'ailleurs de
dollars par deux à trois milliards 2 à 3
milliards en barrant de droits de
transit et en plus elles
s'approvisionnent en gaz les quelques
usines qui restent qui n'ont pas été
bombardé par les par les russes elles
sont approvisionnés en gaz par le gaz
russe qui transite vers l'allemagne donc
en fait il ya beaucoup d'intérêts
objectif mais si la russie décidé de
couper comme une arme politique comme
elle vient de lancer deux pays dans les
normes liste de bêtises que les russes
ont fait il faut pas exclure qu'ils en
arrivent là mais ça serait vraiment le
le sommet parce que justement comme l'a
dit monsieur perrin très justement ils
ont quand même des partisans en
allemagne ses partisans s'appuie
essentiellement sur l'argument du gaz
est peut-être que poutine en arrivera à
sacrifier ça mais je vais il ya des gens
qui vous diront que ça serait le titre
l'allemagne aussi nastasia je pense que
effectivement l'allemagne et ça ça te
dit par plusieurs industriels
mais aussi par la classe politique n'est
pas prête à sacrifier leur développement
industriel par contre ce à quoi les
allemands qui sont assis que même sur
les comités décisif énergétique et dans
le parlement et la commission européenne
ont réussi à faire et c'est la
commission européenne présidée aussi par
ancien ancien ministre de la défense
allemande a dit dans louis mailloux
cette stratégie nouvelle qui a revu du
coup le green dieu qui est de la
continuation de la grille mais qui
contient des éléments très importants
qui nous communique que c'est le charbon
qui va être le en gagnant en des grands
gagnants de sa et l'allemagne tout ça
tombe bien est aussi en des producteurs
les plus importants de l'union
européenne du charbon et n'avait cloud
bi du charbon très important qui
aujourd'hui je pense est en train de
boire le champagne tous les jours france
espère du coup effectivement c'est très
très mauvais pour la planète je puis
dire donc ça serait le charbon qui
pourrait se substituer effectivement au
gaz russe en tout cas à court terme
voilà vous avez prononcé trois mots très
important à court terme l'énergie c'est
toujours très délicat en termes
d'articulation différents niveaux de
temporalité on doit répondre à des
urgences à court terme parce qu aucun
grand pays ne peut se passer d'énergie
c'est vital
c'est le moteur de l'économie ensuite il
ya le moyen terme ensuite il ya le long
terme en ce qui a le très long terme et
une politique énergétique bien conçues
ne sont pas toutes doit articuler ces
différents niveaux de temporalité en
2022 on est face à une urgence ou
l'urgence potentiel risque de pénurie
gazière et ou pétrolières et de flambée
supplémentaire des prix aucun
gouvernement européen ne peut se dire je
m'en moque je ne fais rien ce n'est pas
possible ce serait complètement
irresponsable en même temps le but c'est
en même temps si je puis dire c'est de
ne pas perdre complètement le lien avec
les objectifs à moyen et à long terme
liés à la décarbonation nos économies et
on peut quand même rassemblé les deux de
façon un peu parce que dans l'est la
stratégie européenne pour se passer à
terme quelles ruses pas tout de suite il
y à aller chercher du gaz ailleurs il y
a n'y a pas un nombre limité de pays ces
filières pour aller chercher du gaz
ailleurs comme il y a aussi accéléré le
la substitution d'autres énergies au gaz
notamment dans la production
d'électricité si vous d au pays des
projets eau solaires ou éoliens ou dans
certains cas nucléaire pour produire
plus d'électricité vous aurait moins
besoin de consommer du gaz dont vous
aurez besoin d'apporter de gaz russe
hélas ce moment là vous êtes sur des
énergies non carbonées donc ya pas
forcément contradiction à 180 degrés
entre ses priorités d'urgence il ya la
guerre en ukraine et la décarbonation
simplement c'est vrai qu'en 2022 les
européens font le tour du monde pour
chercher plus de pétrole plus de gaz et
éventuellement plus de charbon et
georges mink est effectivement
l'allemagne pourrait se passer de gaz
russe sans retourner au nucléaire
ça serait difficile certainement mais je
suis assez d'accord avec ce qu'a dit mon
prédécesseur
nous sommes dans une période transitoire
des bricolages certainement où on va
saisir ce qui est disponible mais c'est
aussi une manière de d'aborder un
tournant grâce à ce qui se passe en
ukraine et grâce aux bêtises des
bouteilles c'est à dire qu on va
certainement davantage recherché
d'autres sources à moins à moyen terme
ou à long terme et c'est ça l'avenir et
l'allemagne peut investir dispose de
moyens d'investissement elle peut avoir
une politique verte plus active que
d'autres avec les ressources sur rennes
ouvrables donc je pense que l'avenir le
présent être peut-être grille mais
l'avenir n'est pas noir dans ce cas vous
êtes optimiste jean de gliniasty vous
êtes d'accord est ce que vient de dire
georges mink enfin il faut voir ça comme
un virage plutôt positif oui enfin à
moyen et long terme c'est clair que
moyen long terme ça va accélérer la
décarbonation puisque le gaz était
conservée par l'union européenne comme
une énergie intermédiaire 1
transitoire donc ça va accélérer mais en
attendant avant d'en arriver au stade
vers on va manger beaucoup de charbon on
va manger beaucoup de charme et puis
surtout il ya une inflation qui vint
s'installer francis perrin peut-être de
manière un peu durable puisque hausse du
prix du gaz aux du prix du pétrole je
passe également hausse du prix du blé
enfin tout ce qui est effectivement tout
ce qui est lié à l'alimentaire
c'est parti enfin ça ne va pas s'arrêter
et ses princesses pour le pouvoir
d'achat des européens et pas seulement
d'ailleurs c'est là ça ça va être un
problème numéro un c'est parti depuis
l'an dernier ce mouvement évidemment qui
s'est aggravée avec la clairon du grain
mais ce mouvement de hausse d'à peu près
l'ensemble des matières premières a
commencé en 2021 pour une raison très
simple après l'année terrible 2020 covin
19 récession économique mondiale
l'économie l'an dernier repart à plein
régime
+ 6 % de croissance au niveau mondial et
une économie qui tourne au civic va
forcément consommer plus d'énergie plus
de matières premières et les prix
commencent à décoller et ensuite on
arrive à la crise russo ukrainienne à
l'automne puis la guerre en février et
ça monte encore plus mais c'est un
phénomène qui avait commencé bien avant
mais qui est accentuée évidemment par la
guerre et de façon significative il ya
vraiment un problème par rapport à
l'inflation à l'impact sur le pouvoir
d'achat des populations l'impact aussi
ne faut pas oublier sur le tissu
industriel
vous parlez à des des présidents
de pme en france ou ailleurs qui vous
disent je viens de renouveler mon
contrat pour acheter du gaz + 100 % par
rapport à ce que je payais un an
auparavant comment est ce que je fais
sur mes marche celle pour le gaz c'est
pour le pétrole c'est pour les
carburants c'est pour le charbon c'est
pour l'électricité
c'est pour d'autres matières premières
minières et que donc il ya un vrai
problème pour les populations et pour
l'industrie pas les plus grands groupes
damman qui s'en sortiront toujours c'est
total energy va pas faire faillite parce
que il ya une augmentation des prix des
matières premières mais tout le tissu de
pme en france en europe et ailleurs dans
le monde est concerné et de façon
inquiétante mais on a vu d'ailleurs le
poids de l'argument du pouvoir d'achat
pendant la campagne présidentielle on a
vu d'ailleurs que marine le pen l'a
beaucoup utilisé je ne veux pas toucher
au pouvoir d'achat des français c'est ce
qu'elle mettait en avant donc il va y
avoir ce problème à gérer pendant cette
guerre en ukraine également complètement
et là aussi une réponse européenne
probablement exactement est
dans le plan énergétique notamment you
la commission a déjà indiqué que et les
prête à
intervenir dans le marché par le
contrôle des prix quels sont les
contrôles et des ya différentes façons
de contrôler et de prix on entend déjà
expérimenté certains sur le marché de
l'énergie notamment a donc avec avec des
jalles elle irait jusqu'au contrôle des
prix donc là on est en pleine
négociation parce que pour l'instant à
vous de parler de contrôle des plis mais
c'était déjà mentionné dans tout ce qui
est écrit jusque là sur cette fameuse
stratégie qui doit être publié a publié
plus tard dans le printemps mais
justement donc ça c'est celle
d'intervention c'est une chose au niveau
européen au niveau national on a déjà vu
l'intervention de l'état en france par
exemple sur le prix du pétrole de ducobu
rend justement à la pompe donc ça on a
déjà vu et ensuite on peut aussi
envisager peut-être les subventions
d'état plus important pour les
entreprises et différents types
d'entreprises par seulement les grandes
entreprises mais aussi les pme aussi
différent des tissus donc pour préserver
ces tissus industriels et même pôle
renforcé parce qu'en parallèle de tous
ces problématiques énergétiques on voit
bien qu'il ya le problématique de
récréation ou en force bon 2 tissu
industriel militaire qui se demandent
qui demandé par la guerre de l'europe
georges mink justement qu'est ce qu'on
me dit en pologne face à cette
problématique du pouvoir d'achat rôle a
beaucoup entendu en france on entend
beaucoup en europe occidentale est-ce
qu'en europe orientale c'est une on y
pense aussi c'est quelque chose en fait
effectivement vous avez des polonais qui
en parle de du fait que les prix
augmentent et que effectivement cette
guerre en ukraine oui on va se passer du
gaz russe mais comment va-t-on faire
pour effectivement pouvoir
pouvoir faire face
en pologne on est évidemment inquiets
d'autant plus que l'inflation le taux
d'inflation est à deux chiffres
actuellement et que des problèmes
essentiels du maintien au pouvoir de
l'actuel
[Musique]
droit il parti droit et justice tient
évidemment à la situation sociale qui
peut devenir rapidement explosive mais
aujourd'hui le gouvernement a fait une
annonce de blocage des tarifs au ménage
jusqu'à 2027 alors je ne sais pas où ils
trouveront les ressources pour compenser
la différence mais en tout cas c'est une
annonce qui prouve qu'ils sont
extrêmement sensibles aux effets sociaux
de cette situation et je pense que par
ailleurs évidemment ils vont renforcer
leur politique industrielle en
recherchant d'autres responsables a
ajouté jean de gliniasty effectivement
les problèmes sociaux n'en sont qu'à
leurs débuts avec cette inflation qui
s'installe oui enfin je ne suis pas
particulièrement qualifié de pour en
parler mais je dirais que l'europe a
aussi un autre souci c'est le souci de
la rentabilité de ces entreprises avec
un gaz plus cher parce que le gnl donc
le gaz naturel liquéfié venue des états
unis est beaucoup plus cher que je ne
suis pas sûr que le gaz qui viennent du
qatar ou d'algérie soit plus avantageux
que le gaz russe et dans le même temps
les russes donc vont construire force de
cibler les deux donc ils vont doubler
leurs approvisionnements chinois etc
l'industrie chinoise qui va finalement
avoir l'énergie la
au meilleur marché possible et donc dans
le un monde concurrentiel c'est
évidemment un élément a pendant qu
est-ce que c'est plus cher justement
francis perrin d'importer du gaz naturel
a priori les plus cher que le gaz russe
en général oui effectivement parce que
c'est le transport le coût du transport
la russie exporte du gaz une aubaine
depuis des dizaines d'années donc les
gazoducs à part le nord stream 2 qu'est
jamais entré en service les gazoducs
sont largement amortis donc le gaz russe
il extrêmement compétitif et en plus la
filière gazoduc est moins cher que la
filière gaz naturel liquéfié où il faut
une usine de liquéfaction dans le pays
producteurs ça coûte des milliards de
dollars il faut une flotte de méthaniers
les méthaniers c'est évidemment rien et
il faut un terminal de régal
regazéification du gaz à l'arrivée donc
c'est qu'une filière coûteuse vous
ajoutez trois éléments qui coûte
extrêmement cher mais c'est le seul
moyen de traverser les océans pour
transporter du gaz naturel qu'il faut à
rien il faut investir évidemment mais ça
va coûter cher alors comme l'énergie
c'est vital il est clair que les pays
européens paieront le prix qu'il faut
pour éviter une pénurie de gaz on ne
pourrait pas dire la même chose comme ça
dans un coin énergétique le quoi qu'il
en coûte n'est pas prêt d'être terminé
avec la guerre en ukraine est terminée
alors on va passer justement à cette
dernière arme parce que côté alliés côté
européen on voudrait mettre en place
donc cette ce sixième paquet de
sanctions contre la russie et il inclut
ce sixième paquets non pas un embargo
contre le gaz puis ce qu'on a vu à quel
point c'était compliqué mais un embargo
sur le pétrole russe alors les européens
qui se dirige vraiment vers un embargo
sur le pétrole russe georges mink
ils vont certainement essayer les
dépendances du pétrole sont là aussi
différentiel selon les pays donc on se
trouvera confronté
au même problème qu'avec le gaz et
l'union européenne mettra le moyen qu'il
faut probablement pour tenir une union
autour d'eux une politique commune mais
bon c'est comme tous les prêts
nécessaires longs souligné un avenir
fragile on ne peut pas savoir exactement
si ça va marcher ou pas s'il y aura pas
un mauvais élève
de l'union européenne qui va plutôt
jouer la robe bleue zone que l'eurozone
on ne peut pas savoir ça pourtant on a
l'impression que l'union européenne est
assez unis justement dans ces sanctions
aujourd'hui le miel si vous pensez vous
qu'il pourrait y avoir un sixième paquet
autour de cet embargo sur le pétrole or
use ça devrait être annoncé la semaine
prochaine bon il ya un conseil européen
mais qui devrait mettre ses dires la
dernière la dernière main à ce paquet ce
que je constate c'est qu'à l'heure
actuelle sur le pétrole ça discute ferme
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de pays qui ne
ne veulent pas d'un embargo sur le
pétrole on a l'impression que les
allemands auraient en tout cas ils ont
fait une annonce hier disons qu'ils
étaient prêts à le faire c'était au qui
manifestement été sacré hier les
allemands à se faire pardonner le gaz
alors que nous effectivement le gaz on
fait 10 7% fin ça doit être dit la
conversation est donc nous nous sommes
plus allants sur le pétrole et encore
parce qu'on manque de gasoil il n'y a
pas beaucoup de d'installation en france
bref les discussions vont bon train et
ça sera difficile de trouver une voie
moyenne où l'on trouvera comme toujours
dans le cadre européen anastasia sur les
âmes l'embargo donc du pétrole du monde
donc les discussions se tiendront dans
chaque état est maintenant au niveau
européen les questions se condamne le
gaz qui va substituer la russie donc on
appelle donc ses vingt sept responsables
pour 27 % des importations du pétrole
donc là on soit on parle de réussite de
la récitation de l'iran est devenu tu es
là de leur donc présent complètement des
états parias on peut dire soit on parle
aussi de l'augmentation de la production
du pétrole par l'arabie saoudite qui
pourrait le faire mais pour l'instant
est réticent de le faire parce que ça va
bien sûr impacté les prix et donc lui
frappait elle-même et à maintenir les
prix sont au top quand les russes l
argument est aussi politique donc vont y
perdre le minimum parce que les prix
sont au top et leurs budgets déjà
configuré pour le prix moindre de ce qui
est aujourd'hui même avec le disque
compte mais aussi les autres producteurs
de pétrole ne sont pas prêtes à se tirer
dans le pied et juste pour rajouter sur
ça aussi les raisons pourquoi beaucoup
d'états européens sur les dix ans parce
que l on parle beaucoup du pétrole mais
on parle pas peut-être suffisamment tout
ce qui est le
tout ce qui se vend quand on où on va
avec notre voiture et là c'est
effectivement le 10ème surtout est
impactée et disait ne s'est pas
seulement des diesel auraient été des
voitures en france mais aussi toutes les
camions et tout le transport des
marchandises par le bateau francis terre
alors cet embargo sur le pétrole a
priori il pourrait avoir avant moi j'ai
une question parce que j'ai lu que les
américains ne voulaient pas augmenté
leur production de pétrole alors
qu'effectivement si augmenté leur
production de pétrole vu qu'on est dans
un bloc occidental il pourrait plus
facilement peut être exportée en europe
or il ne veut pas faire pour justement
ne pas toucher au prix la production
pétrolière américaine est en train
d'augmenter
ensuite ça prend un petit peu de temps
mais elle est en train d'augmenter elle
va augmenter en 2022 par rapport en 2021
et en 2023 par rapport à 2020 pas
suffisamment à l'action de pétrolia
suffisamment quand vous avez un géant
comme la russie qui est un géant gazier
et pétrolier il n'y a pas un pays y
compris l'estonie qui apportera la
solution il faut mettre plusieurs pays
ensemble en partie les états unis en
partie d'autres pays d'asie sont les
alliés sur laquelle on se pose même plus
la question en ce qui concerne sûr
jamais la casse le premier accord conclu
par l'union européenne a été avec les
états unis pour des livraisons
supplémentaires de gaz naturel liquéfié
américain à partir de 2022 et monte en
puissance dans les prochaines années
donc les états unis font répondre
présent mais évidemment ça paraît un
petit peu de temps et c'est pour ça que
plusieurs pays etats unis union
européenne au sein de laguiole on
utilise l arme des stocks stratégiques
de pétrole dans ce que vous appelez les
stocks stratégiques de pétrole le
pétrole c'est essentiel personne ne veut
en manquait donc quand vous avez peur de
manquer quelque chose parce que c'est
très précieux vous le stocker sur votre
territoire
on a des stocks de pétrole brut des
stocks de produits raffinés c'est une
obligation quand vous êtes membre de
l'union européenne et de l'agencé ansa
de l'énergie ces stocks doivent
représenter au moins trois mois de vaud
importations pétrolières donc les stocks
c'est un moyen de gagner du temps ce
n'est pas un moyen de régler une crise
c'est un moyen d'acheter du temps en
attendant que d'autres solutions arrive
qu'ils peuvent être l'iran que vous avez
évoquées si un accord sur un accord
quant à la femme le venezuela ça prendra
un peu plus de temps l'augmentation de
la production pétrolière américaine le
temps de convaincre les pays opep opec
plus d'appuyer plus sur comment les
convaincre parce qu'à nastase et disais
bien qu'il ya un problème quand même sur
le prix ne veulent pas augmenter pour
justement augmenter leur production les
problèmes politiques c'est que l'arabie
saoudite les émirats arabes unis
traînent les pieds parce qu'ils sont
mécontents par rapport à joe biden qui
négocie avec l'iran qui est leur
principal ennemi donc ils profitent du
fait qu'ils sont en position de force
pour se doper le luxe de ne pas
décrocher quand le président américain
les appels ce qu'on n'a jamais vus jean
de gliniasty oui ça tu as du talent
c'est vrai qu'ils allaient reus et puis
effectivement les pays du golfe avec qui
il ya d'autres problèmes géopolitiques à
fait exact d'abord le la russie a mené
ces dix dernières années une pipe line
diplomatie est extrêmement active
vis-à-vis des pays du golfe elle
entretient maintenant des relations
extrêmement harmonieuse on n'est plus du
temps de la garde de l'afghanistan
extrêmement harmonieuse avec l'arabie
saoudite l'arabie saoudite a fait
lanterner un secrétaire d'état américain
et elle a dit non à toutes les pressions
américaines lui demandant d'augmenter sa
production c'est la même chose partout
dans le gauche quand on regarde la carte
du monde on voit qu'en fait à part le
bloc occidental personne ne veut prendre
des sanctions et donc il ya un aspect
politique il va falloir convaincre un
certain nombre de pays qui ne veulent
pas de se montrer hostile à la rue cyr
pour la cei nous falloir faire de la
risle politique la négocier avec eux
qu'est ce qu'on donne en échange de
l'insee on est entré dans un tweet proco
comment dire en anglais mais on a besoin
effectivement de ses producteurs de
pétrole en tout cas des pays du golfe et
a effectivement donc quand ça veut dire
justement on a besoin de tout tout tout
l'ensemble est pourquoi je voudrais je
t'ai pourquoi les états unis ne veulent
pas augmenter drastiquement leur
production même si peut-être en théorie
et pourrait le faire peut-être
techniquement c'est parce que les
producteurs du pétrole et du gaz
américain ils ont déjà vu ça parlait
parler relance économique pas c'est que
quand la demande son rôle et son ils ont
sous pression sous pression pour
augmenter la production ils augmentent
et ensuite ça se casse la demande
surpasse le figure et se retrouve avec
la production excessive avec le besoin
de fermer le puits du pétrole ou du gaz
et une fois le puits est fermé elle est
fermée pour toujours et donc là ils
perdent de l'argent et ils n'arrivent
pas à rentabiliser le puits avant de le
fermer parce que le cycle économique est
beaucoup plus court que pourrait être
provisionnés et donc là c'est la
prudence aussi business et la logique
business des américains qui dicte que
que l'augmentation peut se faire petit à
petit et pas d'un coup donc d'où la
nécessité de négocier justement et avec
les pays du golfe et avec les rangs avec
nous et c'est là tout ça en même temps
un compromettant d'ailleurs les valeurs
des états unis leurs propres valeurs
démocratiques sous le drapeau desquels
aujourd'hui les états unis agit donc ça
mais même les états unis même dans une
position très compliqué et démontre
encore une fois que cette leadership
politique globale et n'est plus
peut-être en nous faut c'est être au
rendez vous george mikan ont justement
peut-être que pour conclure parce qu'on
est bientôt à la fin de cette émission
malgré tous ces obstacles malgré
justement cet impact sur le pouvoir
d'achat les polonais continue à avoir
cette cette position très ferme à
l'égard des russes et continue à vouloir
aider de plus en plus les ukrainiens
exactement car le polonais non seulement
pratique cette realpolitik dont on parle
maintenant depuis déjà presque une heure
mais aussi en haute estime la morale et
ils écoutent ce que je lis qui dealent
dit précisément vous allez payer ce
pétrole avec le centre crânien et le
polonais sont en première ligne aussi
donc il faut en tenir compte et je pense
que en tant que guyot d'une politique
européenne vis-à-vis de ce qui se passe
en ukraine la pologne va maintenir une
politique morale
ou l'éthique morale donc c'est ça qui va
prendre le dessus vous pensez également
être en espérant
nous sommes face à une guerre
d'agression
donc effectivement il y à un agresseur
et agressé et ça c'est une question de
de morale ensuite nous sommes aussi dans
un monde où il ya la géopolitique
l'économie l'énergie et la difficulté
pour les états pour les gouvernements
pour l'union européenne pour les etats
unis c'est comment on fabrique tout ça
mais on voit bien que les choix ne sont
pas très moreau forcément ce sens ya
loin d'être toujours loin d'être
toujours oublier toute dimension morale
un mot de conclusion peut-être
arrestation là dessus parce que on
exactement la conclusion c'est sa seule
dimension morale c'est pas seulement à
la rhétorique mais c'est aussi la
bataille qui est derrière tout ça à la
bataille diplomatique peut être pour qui
peut encore aujourd'hui qui a encore les
moyens économiques les moyens de
ressources est le meilleure politique
pour se nommer le leader du monde est ce
qu'il y a un pouvoir ou plusieurs
pouvoirs et c'est aussi ses 7,7 d'où
vient cette importance de la position
morale parce que c'est ça qui détermine
donc aussi les alliances et qui
détermine ce qui soude du coup les gens
en résolution de ce conflit en déviation
fait de la politique au nom de la morale
ou très peu pas disons que ça intervient
c'est
intervient dans le ce que les américains
appellent le soft power ça fait partie
de la puissance c'est mental mais il
faut pas oublier que la morale des
jeunes n'est pas forcément la morale des
autres les chinois font la promotion
d'un système différent autoritaire et c
est peut-être que justement le drame de
la russie c'est qu'elle est à cheval
entre disons la morale occidentale et la
morale asiatiques
merci beaucoup entrées devraient être
avec nos jours de gliniasty merci à vous
georges mink d'avoir été avec ton direct
de varsovie merci anastasia chapeau
china et puis merci avoue francis perrin
merci à vous tous de nous avoir suivis
reste avec nous sur france 24
[Musique]